سرطان القولون هو أحد أكثر
تشخيصات السرطان شيوعًا بين الرجال والنساء في
الولايات المتحدة ، ويواجه الأمريكيون الأفارقة
خطرًا أكبر الدكتورة روشيني راج هنا للانضمام إلينا
إنها طبيبة أمراض الجهاز الهضمي ، شكرًا
جزيلاً على وقتك هذا الصباح دكتور
أنت تعرف سرطان القولون  هل يمكن الوقاية منه ،
وأنا أعلم أنه من الواضح أن
الاكتشاف المبكر هو المفتاح هنا ،
فأنت تعلم تمامًا أن هذا أحد
السرطانات التي يمكن الوقاية منها حقًا من
خلال الفحص وذلك لأن
معظم سرطانات القولون تبدأ على شكل زوائد حميدة ،
وهي عبارة عن نمو سرطاني سابق ينمو
من بطانة  القولون ، ولكن
يمكن إزالتها أثناء اختبار الفحص
مثل تنظير القولون قبل أن تتاح لها فرصة
النمو لتصبح سرطانًا ، لذا فإن
سرطان القولون بهذا المعنى يمكن الوقاية منه جدًا ويمكن
علاجه أيضًا عند اكتشافه مبكرًا وهو
سبب آخر وراء رغبتك في
الخضوع للفحص بحيث  يمكنك التقاط هذه
السرطانات إذا كان لديك في وقت مبكر من
العملية ،
ما هو العمر الذي تنصح بالذهاب إليه
لإجراء فحص
مثير للاهتمام.
خفضت ty مؤخرًا إلى حد ما
السن إلى 45 ، وفي هذه المرحلة يجب أن
يخضع الجميع للفحص بغض النظر عما إذا كانت
لديهم أعراض أم لا أو ما إذا كان
لديهم تاريخ عائلي وهذا هو
الحد الأقصى للعمر الذي تعرفه ولكن يجب
عليك بالتأكيد الخضوع للفحص في وقت مبكر إذا كنت
في سن أعلى  خطر أو أنك تعاني من
أي أعراض يمكن أن توحي
بسرطان القولون وتتحدث عن بعض
هذه الأعراض ، هل هناك بعض تلك الأعراض التي
تبرز أكثر من غيرها ،
نزيف المستقيم بشكل جيد للغاية هو
الذي نتعامل معه على محمل الجد بحيث يكون
إما دم في البراز أو  الدم
على ورق التواليت عندما تمسح
أي تغيير في عادات الأمعاء يكون
جديدًا ومستمرًا بحيث يمكن أن
يكون إمساكًا جديدًا أو إسهالًا يمكن أن يكون
ضيقًا في البراز أو البراز الذي يشبه القلم الرصاص
أو الإحساس كما لو كنت بحاجة
للذهاب إلى  الحمام ولكن عندما تجلس
على المرحاض ، لا يخرج أي شيء ، فهذه
كلها أسباب للقلق ، ومن ثم أشياء
مثل آلام البطن أو التشنج
غير المبرر ، وفقدان الوزن أو الإرهاق.  أيضًا
الأعراض المحتملة لسرطان القولون ، لكن
يجب أن أشير إلى أن معظم
سرطانات القولون لا تنتج أي أعراض
عندما تكون صغيرة ، لذا لا تريد الانتظار
حتى تظهر عليك الأعراض ، يجب أن
تخضع للفحص في السن المناسب
بغض النظر